hey youtubers is Charlie huge news so we
have green lantern characters coming to
arrow season 5 and we have Draco Malfoy
from Harry Potter coming to the flash
season 3 so I'll explain what's going on
there's also some Green Lantern movie
news too so Harry Potter flash crossover
Cisco is gonna go crazy the deal is is
that tom Felton who played Draco Malfoy
is playing a series regular and kind of
an antagonistic sounding role to Barry
Allen inside the CSI it sounds very much
like dr. Alchemy's character from the
comic books so I'll explain that in a
separate flash video but that's what's
going on tom felton going to be a series
regular so we're gonna be in most of the
episodes you know I do not think that
he's going to be another speedster I
think the season 3 you know main
antagonist will be someone who is not a
speedster but lot of speedster things
going on because we have all it West we
have Jesse quick coming back so we'll
talk about all that in a new flash video
tomorrow but on to Green Lantern and
arrow stuff so everyone's always
wondered can they do Green Lantern stuff
on the TV shows because they're not
gonna be doing the movie - like 2020
well now they're like one step closer to
that in it I mean if they actually did a
Green Lantern on the TV shows I think
that it would be Alan Scott because of
all the Justice Society legends of
tomorrow stuff they're doing right now
but now we actually have a Hal Jordan
specific character coming on arrow
season 5 and the interesting thing is is
they have so many characters it looks
like they burned the show to the ground
and this Season 5 version of the show is
gonna be something that looks completely
different so I think everybody will be
really happy with the changes they made
but well you know what the hell is going
on
well they just cast a character from the
Green Lantern universe we're getting
like one step closer to Hal Jordan how
Jordan is like the next Candy Man on the
series which is funny because Candy Man
was the voice of zoom on the flash
season 2 but he's like one of those
characters like Hal Jordan one of those
characters that you speak his name
often enough suddenly he'll just appear
surprise in that way Hal Jordan
is like the new Ted Kord of arrow
Kord industries mentioned so many times
on arrow eventually he's just gonna
manifest out of the ether and if you
wonder why Ted Kord hasn't been on air
yet it's because Warner Brothers has
tied the character up with other
projects up until this point I always
felt like that was going to be the
Booster Gold film that we're gonna put
Ted Kord in the Booster Gold film that
they had planned previously but then
was all this Batman V Superman drama
Geoff Johns taking the helm so there's a
lot of creative things that change
behind the scenes all for the better and
the same thing goes for a Green Lantern
so as part of the DC movie universe
right now the Green Lantern movie that
they had initially planned that's not
set for 2020 and I'm expecting that date
to move around because that's so far off
but because of all the changes behind
the scenes Geoff Johns I think is able
to help arrow the other TV shows do mean
Lantern things in a way that they
weren't able to do before like early in
season four we got the Hal Jordan Easter
Egg we're just getting one step closer
to Coast City in those Green Lantern
characters so the characters that arrow
is bringing on from the Green Lantern
universe is really like Hal Jordans
sister-in-law so she's mostly going to
be a reporter character that's trying to
chase down all of her quick mayor Oliver
Queen for a story so what I'm expecting
is is for them to just have a lot of fun
with Hal Jordan Green Lantern jokes
without necessarily speaking his name
because most of the focus is going to be
on this huge new cast of characters that
they brought on team arrow itself so a
lot of you are asking about Artemis
what's the deal with her so she's being
played by the character that we saw
masquerading as the Black Canary in the
previous season so they kind of set her
up in the episode that she was in during
season four as this crazy badass who's a
younger Thea type character without a
lot of the baggage that the Thea
character has so I feel like Artemis
will be a better version of what the
Thea character is supposed to be but
what about Green Lantern movie things so
I mentioned Green Lantern movie stuff
it's still a like a long ways off its
gonna be Green Lantern Corps the cool
stuff that people are talking about now
is that you know because Geoff Johns has
so much more power in the DC Universe
it's gonna feel a lot more like James
Gunn's treatment of guardians of the
galaxy a very personal film despite
being like this huge blockbuster but one
of the reasons why guardians of the
galaxy as a movie was so awesome was
because it was James Gunn's movie as
much as it was Marvel's it'll feel
really fantastical weird hopeful and
personal in the way the guardians of the
galaxy was I mean it's not gonna look
like our Dean's of the galaxy the Green
Lantern's and the guardians of the
galaxy you know be a very different
group of characters so right now they're
working on Justice League versus
Steppenwolf that's basically gonna be
like the big battle for the Justice
League movie so you're slowly pushing
into galactic characters
and you create the need for Hal Jordan
in the Green Lantern Corps now you have
to remember that there are several green
lanterns from earth they'll all probably
be featured or referenced in some way in
the Green Lantern Corps movie but if
you're not really familiar with like why
Hal Jordan is central to earth the logic
is is that the universe is divided up
into different sectors so like Hal
Jordan Jon Stewart Guy Gardner they're
like the space cops of the sector of the
universe that the earth is inside so
they're not just responsible for earth
they're responsible for a whole bunch of
planets that Earth is a part of so
naturally you can't just roll them out
right at the beginning you know first
there has to be a big Galactic conflict
before they can come along and before
that happens you have to introduce the
idea of galactic characters which is
where Steppenwolf and the forces of
apocalypse come in but you guys let me
know in the comments what do you want
them to do with the Green Lantern's
movie and everybody's talking about
blackest night war of light of course
they're gonna do all those things
eventually but that is getting way ahead
of the story first they have to have
their rebirth movie event like they're
doing in the comics right now that makes
you completely forget about the first
Green Lantern movie they tried to do in
the funny thing is it's so far off that
I think Ryan Reynolds would totally be
game to do some kind of Green Lantern
type joke he's one of those rare breed
of actors that is totally comfortable
making fun of themselves most actors
tend to be pretty insecure so let me
know like what kind of Ryan Reynolds
Green Lantern jokes do you want to see
in the new Green Lantern film but I
would expect to hear more about what's
going on with that when they released
justice like people will be asking about
like okay you've done Justice League now
when are we gonna see Green Lantern
stuff so they'll probably start talking
about it then but all the stuff I've
been hearing about Justice League so far
is actually pretty good so I'll probably
do a video on that pretty soon but
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Sun King you win
a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details if you guys are new to my
channel I do a DC giveaway every week so
usually I talk about that in the DC
related videos that I post so why you
guys wait for me to post that video you
can click here to learn all about Jon
Snow's parentage on Game of Thrones I
just gotta spell it out a little bit
clearer and you can click here to learn
all about what's going on with the flash
season 3 in Comic Con thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
you guys tonight